yo what's up everybody i am thomas
dopeziola whatever you want to call me i
am back with my co-host slash producer
marty o'neal what's up folks as you can
see marty's a lot closer let's go to
this wine out here what's up guys why
we're real wide first off shout out to
trent shout out to our homie trent bong
doctor thank you so much
new actual
like an actual studio table all the
wires are up there's nothing on the
ground the whole rest of this place
looks clean
guys
looking good all right looking real
professional out here it's looking can
we talk about trent for a moment thank
you trent's gonna walk in first of all
he's got locks from heaven all right
he's got these locks that are just gonna
already make you intimidated when he
enters the room he's in a tank top he's
got his trunks on when he walks him in
some flip-flops why because he lives on
the beach that's true that's a true
statement but then he comes in and you
realize oh this one this dude's way more
of a man than i like your senses yeah
yeah yeah we've gotten the past two ages
trying not to get aids restricted to
death so and then he goes and constructs
and builds from nothing like story time
room trent did it all these lights in
the wall trend did it my new set for
review trent did it all of this
trend that should be his instagram name
trent did it that's a great name
actually because he builds houses on in
hawaii he builds houses in trees
tree house airbnbs
this
guy's a genius so shout out to trent for
just crushing it thank you so much look
at look at this setup and then most of
all i'm not doing this hey what's up
marty i'm not having a look around the
camera look guys he's right here now
like where we have a guest
right here marty's right here
guys all right professional oh we'd even
say it this is the dopes usual podcast
we're here to talk about life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between and a rare episode today is
all about accomplishments
let's go amaze your accomplishments guys
stuff we've been alluding to for some
time we've been talking about we can now
talk about so get ready don't wait we're
only a couple minutes in don't spark it
up yeah wait for us if you can alright
um
guys we have been we've kept our mouth
shut
we haven't said a word
we haven't said a word all right
so let's get straight into this episode
like i said the rare one this is all
about accomplishments and this is going
to change i'm going to get a smaller mic
lower because i don't like doing this
i like talking like that so for everyone
out there that's driving please tune
into spotify and or youtube you gotta
see the new setup
this table
this table already you guys can't see
right there but about to get like a
little neon sign in there oh god
i'm excited we don't have chords
everywhere we have chords everywhere
everything signs up
under the table staple the nail oh my
god about to bring the ps5 in here and
just chill this could be the chill room
now we got our time
so let's get straight into this guys
first piece of
insane insane ass news
also do us a favor we never say this go
follow the dope as usual podcast on
instagram go follow we've marty just
told me the stats like we don't even
post on there really are you kidding me
okay we're reaching a serious amount of
people off instagram but thank you guys
yes thank you for the all support on
instagram all our pages so go go follow
that we really appreciate it
with that being said guys
marty
i need you to tell the back story on how
let's just say this let's just say this
we won't even break it yet
we won't even break
not like that cherry won't break the
chair but we're not going to break it in
oh yeah these are just uh these are my
office chairs we're waiting on yo we're
halfway set up goblin and hash house
both told me herman miller chairs are
the only chairs you should be ever ever
ever using they're eighteen hundred
dollars each
to sit who does that to sit down
and then i sat in it and i went oh my
god i'll spend 1800
oh man for anybody that has back
problems those are the ones so we're
waiting on our chairs to come in so
all right we'll make do what we got new
mic stands a new look we're getting
ready with that being said marty
please let these people oh my god it's
been seven it's been ten minutes i can
see your time
nice
okay we started rolling yeah we started
rolling before
all right
we've been putting this stuff together
for about two and a half hours yes all
right
we bought three new mic stands none of
them fit our mic even though this is the
one we bought it's our luck it's just
stuff that happens marty don't tell him
everything just tell them
the start yeah and then we'll roll into
it and how you met these people company
go
okay so guys this kind of this is rooted
in what i always rant about which is the
number one skill you can have as an
entrepreneur one of them is the ability
to follow up and not get butthurt
what do i mean by that it means that big
deals
relationships with people sometimes you
bump into somebody you want to work with
them you want something to happen
through them but it might not be the
right time usually it's not
usually right when you meet somebody it
might not be the right time for you guys
to come together so it takes time to be
able to follow up and keep that
relationship going and keep the interest
going and know that when the time is
right then you make your move and you
don't have to force it you know i saw i
saw this great meme
uh where it was like i i don't chase i
attract
okay and it's like i'm not chasing down
but i am still on top of these
relationships
everything like when we got on it
episode two
like that's how same exact thing
but
start this from the very beginning of my
career with drastic graphics
you know when i was working and helping
some of these really big podcasts grow
from the start
this company malcolm media
was involved they were the producer of a
lot of these shows and when a lot of my
clients went and got rich as [__] and
started
oh we're about 10 minutes yeah it
started blowing up and really started
really really really blowing up world
tour level blowing up
was was when they came into the equation
so i've just been aware of all these
different companies in this industry and
who the leaders are over the years and
who the game changers are
and um
it was probably about a year ago
it was right after they they had a huge
deal with this company moneyline and
when it happened it just inspired me
like i need to i need to try to make
something happen with these guys i know
it's time i know we're ready we're at
the level
and you know we can
go into their credentials a little bit
more but i just sensed and i've had
moments like this in my life where it's
like i just know it's right and i
started moving forward with trying to
make some a big connection happen
between this company and dope as usual
so then it didn't happen right away and
it usually never does it takes some back
and forth it takes not getting all
caught up in your own feelings if
somebody's you know you also told me
five six hundred times yeah malcolm i
mean i'm just making you know i'm just
talking just letting them yeah we're
letting things go so much you wanna you
wanna raise somebody's awareness without
trying bugging the [__] yeah you know
you gotta when you're dealing with
people on this high level you gotta
understand what they got going on and
that you're dealing with company with
hundreds of people and it takes time we
know this from dealing with all of our
brand partners it takes time to get
things done and to
get things to happen that you want to
happen for your show
through these companies i mean consider
what we're doing here we're going out to
the biggest companies in the world and
just pitching ourselves trying to
make a business through it so that's
what this is and it involves tons of
just
communication effectively communicating
every time i communicate with them
through our information decks and
through
our phone calls and through all these
different things so
anyway a couple months went by and we're
just we're just keeping the interest
we're just going back and forth and then
when you know the timing was right we
really brought thomas into the equation
we've been taking calls with their team
and
we're getting to the point now that we
just went actually visited the facility
and i'm i'm sure i'm probably leaving
out a lot now that marty left out so
much fun stuff yeah yeah okay okay okay
let me bring this back a little bit all
right so let me go into a little bit
more detail with this all right guys you
gotta imagine
when i when i first started this [__]
back in 2014 2015 this [__] was like
being behind the scenes was not cool and
i was so far behind the scenes that i
was like damn i really would like to be
a part of a part of this i would like to
be a part of all this cool [__] going on
but i'm a remote person i'm i'm just
back here while all this cool shit's
going on up in santa monica for years it
was like that
and it didn't make me resentful or
anything more than just like
knowing
a
this can happen b
you made it helped make it happen huge
role play your role
because it's not always time like you
can't if i'm trying to come and work for
dope as usual i can't be trying to beat
yola
i gotta come in and fill the role that's
needed
you know that's not the role that's
needed i got to come in and fill the
role that's needed i realized that back
then but there was
maybe a year or two of figuring out like
who's my friend and who's my client and
who's both yeah because it's a very
blurry line that you can get your
[__] feelings hurt if you think just
because somebody's your client you're
going to be hanging around all like
friends and participating not even
hanging around all the time it's like yo
come by
yeah a personal relationship it's always
chill i was always wanting that
but it just wasn't the situation with my
clients i was
they're my clients i was i realized like
i'm a business who can have many clients
i'm not defined
by these shows that i work for it's not
that's not my career but i'm just
managing what turned into be a lot of
clients but there was that element of it
where i'm out here without any friends
too
i'm completely alone
uh with just april and it's like when
you're attached to all this cool [__]
it's like yeah that's cool but at the
same time i'm like just working in my
[__] office it's just yeah yeah just
you know
the grind of it
wait did you roll anything up oh you got
a pretty okay yeah yeah shout out to uh
yeah so thank you very much
um
so let me let me let me interject real
quick
we're not gonna say about all the shows
and everybody but marty helped
look man seon booking tickets and
everything is what a comedian lives on
so marty's essentially going hey here's
your money i'ma spoon feed you your [__]
here but
like with me i am not rich
i'm trying
but the second i got some money that's
why i [__] got the you know what i
mean like yo bro thank you for [__]
helping and making this happen
i feel like those rich [__]
that you work with didn't even once do
that no and it bug it bugs the [__] well
that's just because it's like me it's
like i go out of my way for anybody
but for somebody like yo this kid marty
that just moved from buffalo is crushing
it he's doing so much don't invite him
to anything yeah no comedy [__] him
that's basically how i felt yeah when
i'm talking it's like it's okay it's not
you're working it's fine it's not that
it's more of like
it's not a team it's like oh um yeah
here here like we need to be a team like
i was saying i won't get into it yet but
i'm talking about the pound thing like
that's like day one i don't know how we
always moved like there was times where
i'd have a really great idea
for a product
[__] would go and do it
and just hey thanks hey can i give you
no money some graphics for that [__]
we're not gonna talk about it but
marty's helped a lot there's been a lot
of situations where i could have really
gotten [__] butt hurt and didn't
because i saw the greater picture but
hurt there's been and that's nothing
there's that's [__] nothing compared
to really what uh you know the grand
scheme of things but there was years
where i just knew okay i'm gonna play my
role i'm gonna crush it i'm gonna
this is opportunity all i ever wanted in
life was some opportunity
but i was also starting over cause
april had already been with me for this
whole music run
restart now i'm restarting at the bottom
once i told rosie i was [__] killing
it with packs i go you gonna be broke
with me
you down okay it's cool
you just gotta know
and know that it's going to happen and
yeah you just go all right so sorry
mm-hmm marty when you start doing the
super bowl commercials and [__] they
introduced you to them correct no
oh oh that's just pine sorry that's just
completely sorry it's two separate
things yeah it's all tvs so it's kind of
confused me i thought you met them
through them so i was i was always aware
of them because they were you're
podcasting yeah they were the studio
malca is a production company i guess
you could call it
a to z
okay sorry i know we started ranting
talk [__] here we go
yeah we do a lot yeah they have they
manage nfl players they're deep
we'll get more into that but anyway
you know i just was aware of them
because they were a player in a lot of
the shows that i worked on
and then my boy nick uh nick davis who i
have the book with full-time podcaster
and for everyone out there don't know go
if you want if you like podcasting
full-time podcaster number one what was
it number one selling on amazon yeah it
was an amazon top seller it's on audible
artie's book all right yeah marty and
nix go check that [__] out
before i ever met you you did that [__]
right before right before
yeah i want to go back and watch it
actually because it's probably cute how
[__] much i thought
sorry i know a lot of people like yo
what are you talking about
let's get into this marty's been working
on this deal for a very long time like
y'all just planted seeds planting seeds
put in their head and then he showed
them me not just the pocket they go wait
this [__] got a cult following
outside of the show they had no idea i
did weed [__]
like there's a lot of bigger pictures i
don't tell i know
my [__] trainer didn't know what i
did for [__] four months like i don't
tell [__] what i do
i'm just like oh yeah i just do
protection that's what i always say i do
protection
commercial stuff yeah and then i bounce
because i don't want [__] like
change their opinion on me like oh i saw
[__] full of 40 packs
or i don't know who's who they're like
next time he comes here and that fool's
got money rob this [__] i don't
know who's who
so man i was off topic marty's been
working on this deal for a very long
time he introduced me to them
you want to
bust it out now yeah yeah so i mean so
they oh they run they run what they they
produce and run what shows marty
currently they produce mike tyson's hot
boxing podcast
they produce showtimes all the smoke
with matt barnes stephen jackson
and a bunch of other shows coming out of
there but namely
those two main ones these are the west
coast shows they got all about the smoke
mike tyson and they may or may not have
picked up another show of two super
super high ass dudes
name the dopey usual podcast guys
we are now assigned to malcolm media 100
we went and picked out our set we had
our meeting is what happened we went and
had our meeting guys we walk into what
25 people working in an office that's
that's the marketing oh they're editing
they do the edits they signed that
that's the design team
sales team over here like shut up that's
all just me and marty
like wait there's help you guys yeah
that guy when he met that super cool
dan with the currently he goes oh i just
get all the files and everything and i
get him to the social media guy that's
all i do he's like i'm quality content
what that means is not all he do i don't
want to downplay yeah that's one of his
roles one of his roles all there's so
many different roles that we play within
the show
that i was so nice because it's like
to the level of commercial productions
when i go film for the [__] super
bowl it's that level of setup where it's
like oh i'm quality control so the
editor hands it off to me to make sure
it's perfect before i hand it off to the
social media team to upload the episodes
like
this is going to level up the show so
much that it's hard to even it was just
shocking yeah some of the other big ass
podcasts are there too
like a lot of the big
podcasts i see on tick tock and [__]
like wait that's their set yeah they're
small
like they do such good movie magic guys
like i thought it was a huge room like
no no just this is a little room
i won't get into it but he showed us
like yo we were there to pick out our
space what do you guys want sorry okay
in september
we're moving yeah season three season
three starts september we're moving out
of this [__] building i'm keeping it
for push trees and put and filming but
we are moving guys just the podcast
marty and i are going to be driving into
work now
it's ready we walk in the back there are
about eight production people people
that do lights camera operator this
operator sound this sound that blah blah
blah i go shut
the [__] up like we don't do anything
bro you don't touch anything oh
christina you guys are so cool
i looked at my i tried to side eye marty
and i saw him doing this
try not to
smile i saw it too you're
like try to hold it back
and um sorry i won't get into it name
wise but we checked out a room because
you guys have this room and he goes
marty you'll get a kick out of this
a certain certain comedians
i've already worked for for eight years
helped him start everything
fired marty over a [__] text message
bugged me more than probably bugged him
fired him over a text message parted
ways
a [__] text message after eight years
bro
yeah
uh-huh
this was recent i think because our
who cares
we walk in he goes you'll get a kick out
of this marty you know them we walk in i
just like shut
the [__] up it's their set i'm not gonna
get into everything but they were let go
because you want this room we look at
each other no we're good
and we laugh like whoa tables turn quick
they just fired you over a text
still cool
business business is business could it
cost
but it wasn't a firing it was like a
we're gonna go it was more of a hey i'm
getting fired and i can no longer
keep you but that was before we knew so
i was butt hurt
anyway yeah we walk in and go what the
[__]
now we'll get a different room we're
picking sets like he's like what do you
guys want to be like shut the [__] up
yeah he got it that's why i love him
because he gets it
so that we had to chuckle over that then
we're like no we'll go we'll take the
set next to titan yeah then we go in the
back we walk in and there's a bunch of
dudes doing set [__] i look i'm like
that's mike tyson set
all right hot boxing
cool it's all my ties and [__] set out
like
movie magic
movie [__] magic these lenses make it
look like you're 30 feet away and real
tight but you're just [__] right
there dude their camera work and their
operators must be so [__] good
because i thought that room was filmed
in a [__] mask any one of the lenses
in there is worth more than ourselves
and all of our whole set
so the show's gonna look better okay but
we look at like yo that's tyson's
[__] set man and look left like
that's all about the smoke set and they
go so you'll be here
so what that means is that we're going
to be again recreating the set
in a new on a real set though wayne's
world [__] yeah and when they come back
after they sign they go
wow it looks just like your basement
wayne
that's what we're doing except there's
no rob blow
okay there's no rob loaded just screws
up yeah so
we couldn't have both felt better about
the whole thing there was so much yeah i
was too
excited we were trying to show it like
that but
it's gonna it's such an opportunity it's
such a one in a million opportunity to
level up the show and
retain complete creative control over
the show 100
but now we're talking about a talent
agency a booking agency that can book
not real that can
specialize in booking a level a list
what do you say you want seth gray get
steph curry
oh yeah because you guys are the [__]
guys it's different we're their new show
that's really what's going on we're
their new show that they're pitching to
all their brand sponsors like yo here
they are here's their decks and we have
badass [__] pitch decks like they
just you know they just flew down to
texas so they set up a set a remote set
to film the episode at rogan's rogan and
tyson was not filmed here it was filmed
in [__] texas they recreated a set
and they recreated in new york when
tyson's in new york
guys they break the whole set down like
a movie all the walls collapse
everything gets put away fake break
shocked i was shocked not even i'm not
even done everybody in the back gets
high
[Applause]
i'm gonna like this place and i told
mario like day one
episode one i'm buying a pound of weed
and i'm gonna distribute it through all
the production people go guys
thanks for making our show sick
just to do it and that's what i mean
like thank you we're [__] thank you
because we could have been more [__]
grateful for this [__] even though yeah
we're paying you still
like a pound of weed to somebody like
it's everything
it's just in this new show what i want
everybody to realize is that we're just
the underdogs in this [__] we're the
little guys by the way graduation don't
happen like this not only are we the
little guys but we're blackballed as
[__] so like
celebrities are the only fools that
can't dunk and [__] knock you out in
that room all right
matt mars like what's up you [__]
giant mike tyson what's up your [__]
giant it's my height and [__] oh my god
these are [__]
steven jackson's helping bro
i'm gonna be the shortest guy in the
[__] room
marty would be like yeah you're like you
know maybe a point guard
possibly if you're just going to jump
out even but i'm saying dude we're going
to be in the [__] room with [__]
legendary athletes bro just filming our
show yeah to me
blows my [__] minds and my mom lost
her [__] you know she's a mike tyson
fanatic i'm so happy i was i got the
iphone footage of that one oh yeah i
[__] facetime my mom because i was
like hey look
she's like where the [__] are you
so yeah my mom's a super [__] mike
tyson fanatic bro but anyway guys that's
the big news we've been talking about
okay yeah and they are like
it's easy to get it confused because
they're very in with showtime yes i
confused it too because the way he was
talking about it at the meeting like
they're
they work with showtime they but they
also can work with any like this opens
the door to any big platform that might
want to come work with the show
so it gives us more like
it's not just two potheads
at a warehouse you might get robbed at
you're walking into a professional
[__] movie studio yeah like a like an
ammo show like set up with 35 workers
and production guys and [__] a lot
different it's a lot different gated
parking you pull up we'd lock you up
looking at i was like
i can't wait to come to work
i don't care where i live it's gonna be
so exciting it's [__] shocking guys
like me and marty we we both walked out
we we
we stood outside for half an hour just
going bro what the [__] what the [__]
so yeah guys but the other layer of it
is cool
it's going to free up about four days a
week for me
to just try more content and more
more content barty has four free days oh
starting september marty doesn't have to
edit anymore he doesn't have to upload
he hasn't touched the cameras he doesn't
have to [__] get the files he doesn't
have to do the lights let's do all the
thumbnails do the clips upload
we're gonna start it's gonna be a slow
fade out you know they're to shadow us
eventually they're going to be taking
that over so that we can just be out
doing live shows out there on live
podcast other people [__] only having to
worry about the podcast on the premiere
and the day we film it it's a different
life for me
because now it's like if i look at my
schedule i've been keeping track of what
i do every day for a couple months now
it's like there's not
there there's never a day where it's not
a full day worth of [__] going on
and i'm just at a point now where it's
like i want to build my own brand i want
to build this brand like he's like uh we
were saying in our meeting thomas was
like so you know like he let go of all
of his clients basically um in the
interest of growing the podcast
and
one of the dudes is like
you can go now you'll have more time you
can go get more clients again i'm like
that's not the goal it's i've moved on
to a different chapter in my career
that it's it's about this now it's about
building this brand and doing all the
different things that that takes so if
we can put out a vlog and an episode a
week i'm pretty sure people be happy i'm
pretty sure you guys would be like yo a
[__] vlog of barney and thomas just
getting [__] up yeah oh wait it's
clean channel doing other stuff i don't
know stuff
be cool what are we at
30. we're doing [__] great yes so so
thank you guys our goal like first of
all
there's a i want to highlight this there
was a bunch of mini goals with a with a
big goal in mind first mini goal let's
conceptualize the show and bring it to
life okay season one we started it
what was the next goal by season three
we wanna noticeably have this at a
different level where we're like
doubling our current viewership
just
we're saying this because we're talking
to you guys because we know you're
aspiring entrepreneurs
just me and him you look at that info
deck image that i just posted up in my
story all the different brand sponsors
how many different corporate companies
about 20 of them that we were able to
just get ourselves basically
despite being blackballed to death
despite all the weed [__] despite saying
what we want being explicit as [__]
before the big company came in so that's
something i'm super proud of because it
only we're only 71 episodes in i got 29
episodes left do that pull up we'll see
just for all the numbers all the support
all the watch time hours it's like
it's just so special it's just very
unique and we're just grateful and like
just know that we've we're just now
getting started like i said like this is
like the end feels like wrapping up
season two over these next couple weeks
is kind of like
coming towards the end of this finish
line once we get there a whole new
marathon so i'm [__] fired up i
haven't been fired up like this since
since i realized that we could start the
show
because you get all fired up i told i
told you when you're standing outside
while we were still standing outside the
building i'm like all right my
excitement phase has already passed i'm
now oh it only lasted for 25 minutes
yeah yeah
i was excited until i got the car with
all right what the [__] it's game time
now it's like what else can i get done
right now
it's like when you end a basketball
season you go into the off season you're
just thinking about getting ready what
it's gonna take to go start that next
season it's exactly what it's like right
now every i need to read more everything
marty said sounded great i would have
been like yo guys i think you're making
this possible it's [__] tight
and that would have been i don't know i
would have moved on but you [__]
you understand what i said this will put
like [__] 12 articulated ass [__]
paragraphs together right now i just
want people to understand because we're
a part of the class of the first people
that are using the internet like this
to to
be have your own little small business
and then connect with a community and
then try to give back to that community
i was trying to explain this no none of
the comedians have it like this like
we are
the fans are a part of everything that
we do we think about them with every
decision we make every guest we book
every show theme we go into every
decision every ad partner we work with
we consider the fans first and
nobody else i feel like really does that
they just want to get through their
adrenaline would i say that they don't
maybe just don't watch enough people so
i don't want to be that could very well
be yes i've never and all the people
i've ever worked with i've never had
work with somebody that cared so much
that's in the premieres that's in the
comments but also
they're rich as [__] and famous yeah
they got it no matter what we're not in
the premieres because it it's good look
and it makes us more money and making
smoking money we do it because we know
the fans like yo you know what the [__]
happened in texas told me like we just
got reply right now oh get in the chat
that's what it's for yeah that's the
whole point that's why it's different
because we think of we think of the
people that like the show are just like
our extended friends not just like
people that we can you know sell tickets
to and [__] yes that's really the
difference and that's why we're gonna
have longevity because it's a real
community it's not just like oh we're
hot we're cool we're [__] celebs
we're [__] famous it's like no we
took the stairs to get here
and that's why i've been trying to post
up so much like throwback [__] or
whatever on my instagram because now
that we're experiencing this success now
that this [__] [__] is working that
everything is aligning and
there's like so many little funny little
nuances to it like the [__] universe
is funny while it's all happening
little things we're talking about here
oh yeah
oh yeah that's just making me feel even
warm every time we've
it's all right
we'll get past it watch watch what the
[__] i do
how many times have we said that watch
what happens the universe is on our side
and then look like we walked in the room
go
nah we'll take a different set
not the energy we need in this one
we'll go right by mike tyson like
the option to say that and it was real
but it was funny because he knew that we
were going to take that other set he
just wanted us he knew what was that but
yeah everybody out there everybody we've
met so far and malcolm
very cool
none of them were like hey that guy was
kind of nothing i hadn't i felt left
going
if that's the place i come to work once
a week i'm not mad at that that is fun
that's cool that's a cool environment
yeah they can just do [__] we can't do
yeah they can do there's 12 people to do
[__] everything so
i just so happy to walk in
get [__] [__] based and go all right
i'm gonna take off
marty do you want to go get high after
this or something because now we can
exactly
let's go film that let's go back around
[__] [__] yeah we're gonna crush it
all right all right so that there it is
guys there's the news there's the one of
the one [__] thing in news that we
have i know there's more i'm just
this is the first time we've ever not
written notes i was just hyped new table
everything's [__] going great we got
the [__] deal
and like i like to highlight also we're
not stopping improving the set even
though we're getting ready to move
pretty soon we're just updating
everything we're about to move in like a
month or two
put a couple thousand dollars into the
set [__]
yeah it really does um
so
one more thing marty's shirt insane cool
as [__] that's a custom shirt for the
set that guy made for him i see i saw it
on instagram i hit him up
i'll pop his name up on the screen
splash splash and uh yeah i really liked
it because i love these i thought it
would just match the set so nice so then
he got all fired up and he he made a
video of himself on his instagram making
my particular shirt which is really cool
pretty tight i'll share that i like it
it's handmade out in colorado and [__]
he [__] dries it out on a rock in the
mountains on a rock
it looks like a snake
it's pretty cool man yeah yeah yeah as
soon as i saw it i'm like damn that
look crazy on the side
hey what's up guys just wanted to take a
moment to talk about one of our sponsors
and this is seek geek use our code at
checkout which is dope as usual and
that's gonna get you 20 off of any
ticket before we get into it guys right
now if you download the seat geek app
and your first ticket no matter what
event it is if it's football if it's a
concert if it's an opera if you don't
know what sea geek is let me explain it
a little bit once you download the app
you can search any cons or any venue any
sporting event anything and once you
find the event you want to go to there
will be a green dot by every c or a red
dot green means a great deal red means
not use our code at checkout which is
dope as usual and that's going to get
you 20 off of any ticket it's literally
that easy guys it's the easiest way you
can save money on any event ever whether
you want to go see a concert or a ufc
276 that's coming up you're going to get
the best deal online that you could
possibly get when you download seatgeek
so once again if you're interested in
anything if you want to go anywhere
remember go outside go have fun if
you're going to do anything remember to
use our code that's dope as usual that's
going to get you 20 off of any ticket so
go ahead and download the c geek app
right now and go do something
all right twitch dopeziola dope
underscore as underscore yola that is my
twitch i just got my pc got my cameras
got my [__] my extra monitors coming i
got my keyboard got my mouse i got
[__] everything ready to go so to
start streaming next week
we're gonna go hard and i already talked
to franklin he's coming over we're gonna
do gta [__] live before i can get
high as [__] we gotta set it up because
soon marty's going to be able to like
marty you want to come hang out you know
for a couple hours like yeah
i don't have anything to do right now so
yes my kids are at school like that's
going to be epic you've never had that
yeah
you went from being a kid to having kids
and working until today yeah
yeah i haven't hung out since you
haven't hung out since yeah so i think
it'd be very cool for you
um yes twitch dope as yola dope
underscore like i said everything
um
twitch is starting pc looking good
everything's tight
so i want to get on to one more piece of
information
a pretty cool [__] win
this whole episode man sound it's just
so bomb do we talk about rosie's [__]
yet no oh we didn't there's more win
you guys know i grew up [__] poor
[__]
you guys know that you guys know all
these things about me you guys have
heard it and it's awesome
i mean being poor suck dick i'm saying
this is awesome now like i talked about
the other day it's like playing check
like your kid here's some money like
that's how i'm living it's so
[__]
weird i went to the toy store
frankincense and spent so much money and
went the little me is dying inside going
oh god i wish i could be there with you
but i wish you could too [__]
get out of here and then
um i'm high
so rosie and i are having in
conversation are you sure we didn't talk
about this on the show
we haven't about her yeah we have it
rosie i want her i want to get her a car
i want to get her car we always have to
uber even though we're adults and [__]
we live here we're not poor so like yo
why don't we just get you another car
like yo
let's do it
and i know what rosie wants and we went
to the porsche dealership and went oh my
god we're in a poor [__] dealership
there's a businessman over there that's
how i felt like that guy's got a tie on
shopping
i'm an adult oh my god dr drew's in this
[__] yes there was dr drew's in
there i was in pasadena too like dog
doctor dude's about to walk in and i'm
gonna be here in my [__] shorts and
vans
they don't take me serious anywhere i go
until they go no no i want to can we run
the credit they don't take me serious
anywhere i go because it's just like hi
but [__] them
anyway i'm like hey look at this 911 and
rhodey rosie found a 911 red on red it
was bomb as [__] i looked down and go i
can't fit in here
so he left i thought i was always
missing something so small they're
badass
it's small i can fit in there
but i'ma look like bowser from [__]
mario kart
i'm gonna be like this hanging out i'm
gonna roll it down just so i could fit
in the car
so when rosie we should think of
something else how about the panamera
i'm like that [__] looks like a [__]
tesla so we just didn't do it
but the uh the fact that went rosie when
we left him can you believe that we just
went into a porsche dealership
not just to look because you kind of
want to get one like this is [__]
incredible i saw the price of it ow [__]
anyway
it's weird right it's weird not being uh
struggling it's [__] odd
the other day we're looking for so
anyway we're actively looking for a car
for rosie i'm like [__] it whether we
get you
anything it doesn't matter we just went
to porch because like [__] let's go
check it out
and then
we're driving around i see a g wagon
like that's a tall ass truck she always
wanted the gle there's an amg it's a
glee it's a
suv right she always wants it she has it
on her screen saver she's always talked
about like one day we'll get it it's
[__] expensive like well one day
we'll get it because i had my blue car
the mercedes on my screen saver and
that's our car it's both of our cars but
there's always a car that she wanted so
we're arguing i'm like nah that [__] is
the same height that's the argument like
no the g wagon is tall as [__] like
rosie it's the same [__] height you
think you're gonna want that car because
we're still talking about cars you want
that car how big that [__] car is are
you sure you're gonna want to drive it
like it's the same [__] height i'm
saying it's the same height i'm high for
everyone out there
[__]
jesus christ
put this joint down
it's the camera angle it's [__] me up
ready you want another light i have one
oh my god my storytelling skills just
went out the window
stop one second
this is [__] sorry for everyone
driving what the [__] is this guy
talking about
boom i mean rosie you're driving around
i see a g wagon i go that's a big car
and she goes the gl is smaller i say no
it's not it's the same height she goes
thomas it's the same [__] it's i say
it's the same height she goes thomas
it's so much smaller i tell her the gle
is the same height are you sure you want
that car
it's too big she hates driving the big
cars now
so i go rosie we're gonna drive two
hours to kill
to form a meeting i go we're gonna go to
mercedes right now and i'm gonna find
the car and i'm gonna stand next to it
and show you i walked in i was wrong she
was completely [__] right i was hella
wrong i went whoa
yeah the gl is the same height as me i
thought it was like [__] six three
it's like [__] five nine at most yeah
it's like it's a very it's like a cool
shape i didn't realize i'm like rosie
you're right so we walk into the
mercedes right morgan mercedes go hey do
you happen to have an amg gle suv
and he goes
i have one and i just got it go [__]
all right let's walk it's just some
random dude
i mean uh car salesman just happened to
stop us like what these kids want oh
what do you guys need to know do you
have it and he goes i'll show you we
walk in to the showroom floor of
mercedes and the car that rosie builds
on mercedes the same package
the same click this click that for seats
click this for rim click that you know
you build a dream car
it's the same [__] car
on the showroom floor the only amg that
they have
with the thing on the top a little
exclusive something i look at and go are
you [__] kidding me you're right yeah
it is the same height as me i thought it
was tall so i'm like first off i'm wrong
second off rosie
get in this car
she gets in it
and it's the same car she's always
wanted like a movie
i look at the price and i go
oh my god because mercedes discontinued
63s
for amg so now there's only five threes
the six three of the car she wants is 70
more
and it's a it's a gle it's an amg 53 the
car right in front of us rosie's in i'm
like rosie
i think we can get this [__] car
and guys
little me
i remember being so hungry in high
school because i had no money and i was
too proud to ask my grandpa for money
and this is my mom disowned me and
[__] wrote off her rights so i didn't
get lunch tickets because i was
technically under my dad in oregon so i
didn't get lunch tickets
my mom would have my dad had to sign me
up but he lived in oregon so i i just
told my grandpa i got lunch tickets
because it was just me and him living
together i'm like i am not asking my
grandpa for money
no way [__] that so i would just not eat
but not eating is not good for you you
should eat
so
i was so poor and so broke and i
remember looking at the car going
buy it
we bought rosie's car right then and
there guys
we [__] got the car i remember i told
you i'm like whoa
oh
my god i can't believe he goes no you're
approved i'm like i know i am now i
didn't even have to look and i know i
[__] got it when he drew walked away
and went rosie's like are you sure
are you worried
she just want to run our credit like i
don't give a [__] by it and that in my
mind i just screwed nine feet and went
and then shook off all that little kid
[__] where i was like god i hate being
poor so sorry i'm not in no way am i
saying bragging [__] i am saying
redemption [__] you're like before us
when this yes when the [__] knee
braces break off like i'm in simon burch
and if i just started getting taller
that's what the movie's happening right
now i am truman and i finally [__]
went i'm leaving like yeah and left all
that [__] went rosie you just bought
yourself a [__] mercedes on the
showroom floor [__] he went took
the [__] sign off as soon as i said
it he put a ribbon on it and put salt on
the window and i looked there like oh my
[__] god he goes by the way i have to
go with you to the bank you know damn
i have to actually watch you take the
money i'll go he's like it's a policy
for us jesus christ [__] are
scammers i guess yeah because i'm sorry
i had to ride with him to go to the bank
the bank denies you your money again and
[__]
not even that i got the whole [__]
money order everything's great super
sick i'm pulling back up to the [__]
mercedes i go spongebob
she spelled my name right
no no she spelled the cal star motors
wrong she spelled it car star
i went yo she spelled you guys his name
wrong is that good is that okay goes
no no you can't you can't put the wrong
person put the wrong [__] name on a
check and i told her
told her and i wrote it on paper it's an
honest mistake but i remember thinking
of course
bank was closed when you went back no
but i went back and they let me not wait
in the long line i went oh [__] what
oh my god [__] is popping today i just
couldn't believe like
this worked the first time in my life
there was no hiccup
you know us there's a hiccup i went no
rosie bye
so by the time i went to my meeting i
got we had her [__] it's [__]
incredible guys i couldn't i couldn't
believe it we picked it up the next day
anyway that long ass elongated story was
me just mumbling
sorry but yes we finally got rosie
amazing so [__] cool i'm so stoked
i've been driving it more it is so fun
it is better than my [__] blue car i
love i didn't know i like suvs i've
never driven one in my life ever yeah
never driven one behind the wheel
wow oh a tahoe once but that was it it's
got full [__]
chiropractic style massage chairs yes in
the mall those ones yes the ones from
the mall that's the chairs i have rosie
has in the front seats
for the first day we got it we just sat
there for like 30 minutes i just hit
hash pins all this [__] to different
stuff to buy them
i felt like such an adult so the first
people ever at the table with like a
corporate company they're about to sign
the deal with ripping double hashtags
oh during the meeting because the owner
of the company during our meeting for
mauka is just ripping a joint
like that i go shut
the f they'd be so happy
okay
so here's a little old me i go wait
like we're cool to smoke
and he goes yeah yeah i go all right
cool cool
they don't rip hard enough if you only
do one they don't see that
i'm trying to hit a dab but i was
ripping these hatch pets the whole
meeting i was just laughing like my life
this is amazing
they get high too
that's when i knew that's when i knew
too like i love this place
up until that point i put everything all
my energy into this deal
but at that moment i was like
this is right
yes
don't remember what we're talking about
i'm [__] hot why am i so high today
oh we woke up early and came straight
here started smoking i didn't wake up
early i'm saying like this is the first
thing we did usually i've had a couple
hours before we start
i woke up late all right
i'll go [__] late today that's why i
feel off damn it i was out there ripping
balls at probably 605 this morning oh my
god
i like to think i'm dedicated i like
feeling like i'm disciplined you are you
are dedicated that's dedication roll you
have to teach someone's outside yeah i
would do this i'd walk up to my table
hit it and
run back to my room while i'm blowing my
smoke out i am not going outside to
smoke boulder i'd rather just wait till
i wake up [__] i'm the david goggins of
weed smoking wait and you stayed awake
yeah oh i thought you meant you smoked
it and then like going back to bed yeah
the party starts about 6 10. i get what
you're saying i get what you're saying
now the party starts
[__] outta here look at our wide angle
over here man let's go look at a real
team we gotta put something right here
yep something fun for a couple episodes
yes
for some episodes
um
okay yeah that was the news i wasn't
even talking about that completely
[__] car
we don't to get deep into this you said
news it made me think of it but we might
as well talk about it because it's super
important i mean this
massive
shift in our human culture of america i
don't even think we should do it no you
know why okay cause you two's gonna come
after us
you they are you know they are i thought
about it this morning
just gonna let the politicians talk
about that one
we don't even say it it's the dumbest
[__] decision i've ever seen going
but you but you're a dude
[__] you got to say about this issue
hold on and let's leave it at that
because you know we're being fun today
you two we're not saying some [__] get
age restricted on this dude we got age
restricted on two episodes in a row age
which not even demonetized [__]
blocked the video
it's the worst thing it makes us [__]
feel like so too yeah what a
years great episode
just chilling yeah like it was all
motivational it was motivation he was so
positive and he has completely homie
about those last two episodes because
youtube is brutalizing they really got
us on that one we're scared to talk
about current events and [__] about this
episode dude wait till we which we're
into the what's up where did we go the
other studio go hey
this is our friends now
you got to leave them alone oh my god
thank you so much
[__] it's one of the biggest things
instagram hey youtube yeah sorry real
quick today's the 23rd 25th [__] off is
it really
i told my daughter 10 years ago
you had the police at your fourth
birthday party
and then what was her birthday party
this year barney on the [__] newport
beach people ran into airbnb for a 14
year old's birthday
[__] they're brushing it over there
right literally
on the beach
there was [__] police at your party
in buffalo
look at you marty will call me sorry
real quick this has nothing to do with
anything marty will call me and he
probably did it
10 times total but that's kind of a lot
i think it's funny he calls me just like
this and i know that face and i'm like
oh what do you got to say man what's
going on and that face like tell my kids
how good they got it
tell them what it was like to grow up
and i'm like
my mom was on drugs and i didn't eat a
lot
i was just like what do you mean like oh
when i was 12 like oh when i was eight
like no you guys are good you have both
parents you all have your own devices
and you have air conditioning you don't
got to worry about gang violence you
haven't [__] made
thank you thank you see what i'm talking
about ariel that's what he does every
time like you see
thank you thank you you know what's
[__] up is that it's like in order for
her to listen to me hurt like you gotta
tell her or one of her friends some it's
like starting to happen where her
friends and her friends friends are
starting to be super fans of the podcast
organically
without knowing that
and then finding out
shout out to all these kids that are
like
talking good about the show to my
daughter good man
that helps
yeah man so sorry i know that's off
topic but marty hits me with that every
so often tell them how good they got it
man oh man you don't have to do it to
anybody else but her but she's way older
than the other kids too not way older
but you know yeah i had a i thought of a
funny story tied into that whole time
frame
uh yesterday when i was driving around
my travis barker story what happened
oh wait i told you not to tell me yet
yeah yeah yeah tell it what's up guys it
happened right around this
talking about ariana having the police
at her fourth birthday party and [__]
all this
jerry seinfeld not seinfeld jerry
springer [__] situation unfolding
with my family and all this [__]
all right
talk about dedication
so i told you the night my dad died
i was supposed to move to new jersey the
next day
yes
so
we we don't need to rego through all
this [__] but we went back i was the one
to find out he actually had passed
you know i was almost basically getting
ready to say goodbye to him anyway
on a level because i was just so
desperate to make something happen
i knew we had to make this move we were
moving to
new jersey to stay with april's aunt for
a while
because they had a really nice house and
they you know like we just wanted to
save up to try to buy a house try to
make a play to try to [__] get out
here
so i was literally going there to say
goodbye to my dad knowing that i was
going to move and i might not see him
again
and uh april went in to talk to him and
um you know when i went in to talk to
him he was passed out so then
a week went by
and uh we had his little funeral and
stuff
and
after that we went to new jersey
so i packed all our [__] into a u-haul
by myself
and uh i left way too late
and i drove off to new jersey and that
was the time where i was like smoking
joint [__] and there was a roadblock i
went through a road yeah yeah police let
me go and [__] with all of our [__]
driving down to april's families
so a lot of people probably go through
this you end up living with
like a relative
while you're like an adult we were like
arianna was like
three or something this was right before
that birthday party incident so we're in
our early 20s or whatever that their
whole life their whole house i get there
late as [__] not cool already kind of
starting off in a bad foot i get there
like 2 3 a.m in the morning pulling up
with the u-haul april and i are going to
get there and now we're living in new
jersey central jersey kind of like super
suburban really nice
i'm
i'm trying to be close to new york city
so that i can
you know get my music going that's the
whole point yeah they're by new york
city so
as soon as i got there i found a studio
i'm pitching my [__] i'm
not working around and [__] i had a
light couple little very light
connections in new york city
um
but i also got april's family looking at
me
like
you guys are broke
[Laughter]
because we are the pointless for us to
save up money you know you're just broke
like we both worked that's just it
wasn't cutting it
i don't know what the [__] it was like
we both worked and we were always broke
but so was everybody and everybody
always worked
like america i don't know how that
always was the case
so
i had to uh
i had to try to find a job
i was doing graphics i was just starting
to hustle graphics
you know i was i would go into every
single city on craigslist this is just
when i started doing this name the city
in america i had a favorites list of
every city their arts and media design
section i would go and i would be
refreshing these pages [__]
constantly geez looking for new job
postings to respond to
and then i was just on craigslist just
did that that was what i was doing in
this phase i wasn't i didn't have the
skills to go get a real job doing this
[__] yet
so i found on craigslist the job doing
mortgage insurance
not graphics
i had to find a job because i was
[__] broke as [__] and living with my
wife's family and they they wanted me to
be saving money so even like right away
like
right away we were kind of restarting
our lives out there we put around in
preschool
and um
so i found this job
and
it was with this dude this older dude
he's probably 50. he lived close to
where she lived
and he kind of takes me under his wing
now he's like i can tell he's a
religious dude
like like a bible dude
and i could tell that this company kind
of has like religious undertones
but it was something
religious
it was something okay so hello focused
i'm sorry keep going i feel like it's
going to be such an odd ass way that
travis parker comes in yeah you know
religious undertones
so i'm telling you that to let you know
just this is uncomfortable for me i'm
not i couldn't want to do this [__] less
i'm a [__] rapper
i'm a [__] i'm not here to push my
rap career forward no word for [__]
jesus corporate
i'm a [__] rapper you think i want to
be doing this i get what you're saying
okay so you do a mortgage insurance so
yeah
so now i'm having to learn this i have
to get
licensed by the state in order to start
working
so i have to shadow this fool for two
months before i even get the chance to
get paid
maybe it might have been a month it
might have been two months
it wasn't that long white slavery
was that man white or not
white is dude alive couldn't have been
white still white slavery yeah white on
white why not white slavery yeah so
he um
so he's kind of acting like i'm gonna be
like his apprentice in this and that's
cool because he's got a big ass house i
can tell he's doing well i'm trying to
make something
you're a young dude like this one has a
plan i'm younger i can't see what he's
doing
like coming out of lackawanna like just
trying to make something happen anything
i need i'm at ground [__] zero here
just moved in with my wife's family we'd
we had had our own hot like rental
houses and apartments and [__] before
leading up to that
too soon ground zero joke when a new
york joke was too soon come on
i know you said i went damn those were
closed together
sorry continue i'm just talking
lock wanna
so i start
like
doing all this training and [__] to get
licensed for insurance and [__] new
jersey
and i'm going back and forth to
philadelphia with him like i would drive
him
it's a couple hours maybe like central
new jersey to phillies maybe two to
three hours
so but it's like pressure i'm like on my
toes around this dude like i'm kind of
he's looking at me as the probably white
trash like
cleaning up how i talk and [__] and like
kind of like hey i can tell you like i i
was going through a lot you know i mean
like i was just real rough still trying
to have a real job marty was deaf jam
fight for new york still
trying to be corporate
just trying to do anything i didn't ask
for this [__] job marty was still
stopping his tim's when he walks in yeah
right 100 yeah
so
but i had to make something happen
because now i'm under the scrutiny of
april's family you know
not not in the back we're looking at
everything in their house we were broke
yeah i just thought about that
i get it you're living with someone's
family yeah you're automatically doing
this i'm sorry i'm not bad am i bad i'm
trying to be quiet my bad yeah
i order out i you guys are [__] i'm
sorry but
but even through everything they're
watching that you buy even they're not
they're being they're amazing yes
they're not doing that but for you going
if i was flipped yeah like
come on [__] were you buying
[__] out of here
that's how you feel because i can and
mind you you know my dad had just died
like a week ago
so like out when that happens it's like
that's why i knew i could do the podcast
the day after my mom died because i knew
beyond that it's going to be a [__]
year before i didn't really talk about
this [__] i came in here the day after
my mother and did the podcast true
you know so because i had already gone
through
that type of [__]
but
go back to now i'm
24 23
in there and dealing with the [__] for
the first time
you know so that's like that's pain that
hits and waves
it never ends
you know it's like but i was fresh to it
i hadn't
i hadn't dealt with any that level yet
anyway or
witness
my mom go through that it was just it
was a weird time and i'm under a ton of
pressure now
you know so
uh
i started doing this training and i'm
shadowing him meaning we go out on a
saturday okay
let me try to frame this so people
understand
we're selling people mortgage insurance
i i don't think mortgage insurance is a
fraud it's not it's not a scam
but it's like
it takes a lot of sales it was almost
like collections
so
for people that had expressed interest
in this mortgage insurance
he's got a whole stack of papers of
these people and he's kind of just
showing up at your house
like hey you had said you were
interested in this maybe we already
followed up with you [__] 10 times
but let's talk about this mortgage
insurance
so we're driving around
central new jersey
doing this [__]
and it doesn't always really go well you
know like we'd hit a bunch of houses
some houses we'd go in we're just we're
[__] going to random people's houses
sitting at their tables just mid life
for them they're just going about their
day this really isn't even scheduled you
know to be like they took a survey they
said they might be interested in this
[__] at one point
and he's going in there as a salesman
that's movie [__] yeah that's real yeah
i didn't know that was real that sounds
horrible couldn't as for somebody that's
an introvert that doesn't like talking
to people oh
no
i didn't even think about this you hate
humans and [__] you don't want to be
around anybody that you don't oh marty's
you're like me sometimes
i hate being in a situation i don't want
to be in yeah i'm there yeah i'm fine i
was used to it more at that phase of my
life i was i had done collections
though did you have to go up and talk to
people this is in person
this is in person you're door knocking
more than april didn't yeah yeah for
this little run
and
but he's also like taking me down to
conferences in philadelphia like you
know like leadership training
you know where like people from all that
are he was grooming you
for this [__] business like
it was cool there was it was all right
like these people are all wearing ties
and [__] and they're all
you got one pant leg rolled up yeah i'm
not we're tim's and [__] i know yes i
can see you yeah you have a beanie but
it's tilted i'm just i'm here this is me
then now still yeah like
new york yeah it's cold yeah and i was
just young i hadn't
done anything yet i was just you know i
was i was stoic still i was me i was
just
i had to live this whole life to just
try to make my own life happen so i'm
here with you but really i'm actually
over i'm this my self is off in the
[__] future somewhere
and i'm i'm lying to you to pretend like
i give a [__] about this
to try to
somehow use it to get over to where i
want to be that's it and for everyone
that's stupid and high he's not talking
about this situation no he's talking
about working for the man that he was
working for so he can go around every
job i had before this situation
everything
yeah every job i have you're in a
situation where you got to pretend that
you give a [__]
and not be yourself that's what bothered
me so much about it i'm not 10 hours a
day i can't be myself
and not to mention who i'm actually
trying to be
is like off in the future somewhere i
got to work to even get i'm not even
feeling like myself yeah that's how i
was i had years of that [__]
but so i appreciated the little
leadership training seminars they had i
had never been to anything like that i'd
drive them down i was even nervous just
driving this [__] big-ass yukon i was
just on edge
i was not nervous but just eggshells
yeah like an apprentice would be to an
older dude
knowing i'm working a job for like two
months not getting [__] paid
so did you start getting paid
so
here's where it gets interesting i'm
just trying to set the scene here so you
understand
that i'm under pressure because i got
april's aunt april her husband everybody
kind of looking at me like
oh you're going you're doing going to
philadelphia and all this and you're
going there every day but like you're
not getting paid oh you got to get
licensed i get it but you guys are
supposed to be saving money you guys are
broke as [__]
like i freely felt that but
when i i went and i did the test to get
certified for the state and i passed and
they like were super happy it was very
supportive very couldn't have been
better
so i passed this [__] test so i could
get paid
we'll say two and a half months has
passed
of all this [__] so now i can finally
i'm in the position to get paid finally
all right so day one rolls around
literally day one of like now i'm on the
books as an actual person that works
doing this [__]
mind you when we had gone and been
riding around doing this [__] there's
also instances where like people are
like yo get the [__] out of here of
course get the [__] out of here and
chew us out of the house and [__] so
there's a lot of that too in this
so i hated collections i did collections
for years at this point hurt my soul
every day i was in there every minute i
was in there i hated
so now i sit down on the table and it
starts getting real collections he hands
me a big ass stack of papers like this
hey these people expressed interest at
some point let's call through these see
if we can get any responses i was used
to calling people not a huge deal
okay but at this time now i'm still
pitching my music
travis barker was coming to philadelphia
and i knew it
he was going to a mall to do an
appearance
i had my demo i had the sick ass travis
barker give the drummer some graphics i
made
printed them out
i had a manila envelope
that i was gonna [__] give him
because my plan was after that incident
with 50 cent happened
i said if anybody that can
be a game changer for me if i ever get
within range of them i'm just going to
start going in on them
i'm just going to start [__] rapping
at them and [__] as soon as i get within
range of them
just because you can't you can hear me
look this
that was my plan because once the 50s i
wish i had did that when i met 50. if i
would have just gone in on them things
would have been different
when you're in a situation
i mean i would it would have shook [__]
up
when you're in a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity with somebody don't don't be
too cool
i mean you might depend
too nervous too sometimes that too i
mean he had just [__] finished
freaking out on a guy yeah sometimes you
don't know you might not see the dude
again that type of [__] but in
retrospect i said
next i don't get chances like this a lot
so you have a vanilla envelope so that's
what i mean envelope you have everything
the graphics your music your pitch
i got philadelphia one stack of work
yeah i got a one sheet which is me
picturing me all my information my demo
travis barker graphics i had maybe three
of them he was gonna sign one bro keep
this my plan was to astonish him with
the graphics what the [__]
go in on him give him the demo walk out
the [__] back door of the deal that
was the point that
could have happened he was on
[Laughter]
my plan was you know my plan i was gonna
flex like this to go i'd be a great
husband that you walk out like let's get
[__] married
you had the mind of like a 12 year old
like you know what you sounded like
remember that movie where the kid breaks
his arm angels in the or the kid breaks
his arm and then ricky there ricky the
air yeah and he has a great arm yeah i
thought that [__] was possible uh-huh
and if i did it it would happen to me i
once landed my arm
free falling just like [__] playing
basketball yeah kind of excited it hurt
but it didn't break my mind yeah that's
your mindset like i'm gonna go here
check out these crabs you can go
that's what he's gonna say and then
you're gonna wrap his ass off and he's
gonna go
i need you on my team we're blink 183
now yes you're the rap front man
i love that that's what you had in mind
that's that was my whole life but you're
thinking so guys remember marty's
thinking about this
stack of work right here did you do the
work
here's where it gets interesting oh
no
what's up guys just want to take a
moment to talk about one of our longtime
sponsors all of 2022 marty and i brand
ambassadors for miller lite
as you guys know we say it almost every
podcast even before this was a
sponsorship don't drink and drive please
be responsible i say it every single
time you already know 3.2 grams of carbs
96 calories for every single can and for
everyone out there it's summertime go
outside go hang out but if you're gonna
be drinking drink responsibly like i
said and if you're gonna drink beer make
it a miller light the beer sponsorship
of the dope as usual podcast right now
go to millerlite.com forward slash yola
that's gonna take you to a landing page
and like i always say it's going to take
you to every single place in your area
that delivers beer and if you don't want
to wait go to any single place on earth
that sells beer
we've said it many times miller light is
the light beer for people that like the
taste of actual beer thank you guys so
much for supporting and as always go to
millerlight.com forward slashiola and
that's going to take you to the landing
page for everyone that delivers
celebrate responsibly from the milwaukee
brewing company in milwaukee wisconsin
man we're back from travis that was like
a commercial break oh yeah you're in the
middle of a storm we've never done that
no i noticed that [__] was about to run
out though yeah the battery's about to
die soon oh commercial break i know did
we just do that in the middle of a story
and then we should do that more right
before the outcome of the story i like
that i was [__] up
if i was at home so maybe i don't know
how we should do that but that was tight
part two next week folks oh hell no bro
i would [__] throw this flip this
table over here
[__] that [__] no could you imagine we
just ended mid-sentence
all right so
done
okay boom
travis park you got the work you said
this is where it gets interesting to
join ready go so it's my day it's my
literally my first day of work now after
working for free for probably about
eight weeks getting certified in the
state of new jersey to sell insurance
so i start calling all these people
just like collections [__] you [__] you
don't call me eat a dick [__] you
you know maybe i think i booked one or
two maybe appointments there was there
was a literally the stack of papers was
[__]
huge
so out my plan was i was only supposed
to work a half a day
it was like it was saturday i'm pretty
sure i was gonna do like eight to noon
so
i got through the stack of papers i had
all my [__] i was gonna go right from
there
speed down to this mall in philly
find travis barker
all right so i get through the stack of
papers i'm like okay
that that went well uh
i let him know hey i called everybody
here's all my notes or whatever
and he's like great well uh let's get
lunch and then we'll flip it over and
you call him again
call him again uh-huh for what
try to get more people on the phone
the same people the same ass stack
the same call the same people again
he said that's what i just said i
remember verbatim because when he said
it my heart sunk
because i was like i'm supposed to have
a half day today
i gotta go be travis parker
and when he said it i was like
hold on what the [__] am i doing
who the [__] am i again i thought that
to myself
oh and i'm gonna like i said i'm in a
weird place my dad just died my mom's
kind of going off deep on i'm i gave up
my house i gave up my job
down here they're looking at me now
and i'm like
i gotta go down to this thing for my
music and he's like
basically like if you do that
don't come back here
but he told you you're only going to
work a half day yeah and then he said
that sprung it up then it was like yeah
cause in his mind you know this is my
priority i'm down there i'm a young kid
i got a kid
my my mind should be on this opportunity
he's giving me i get it flip that [__]
over and call him again
we'll just go you know we'll go till
four
it was saturday how long was he there
till
it was in his house
shut the [__] up you had an office at
his house yeah
so i mean his wife his kids are all
[__] in the house
yeah
uh
so
i got pissed
and i go down in the basement and i'm
like [__] you know to myself
[__] you know the [__] i am
while you're standing in front of him no
this is i went i was like because i went
up he was like out of eating he's like
get some lunch flip that flip the paper
over i'm
i like
i like told him what i going on and i
went back downstairs
and i and i said that to myself
and i just left
and i was like yeah i don't i don't know
i gotta go i gotta go
and i knowing yeah
knowing that i just work for this
[__] for
this time for free and now it was all
for [__] nothing and i was gonna have
to go back and explain that after we
just had a [__] celebration party for
me getting licensed ah
marty what movie what ben stiller movie
is this man what's it called this is ben
stiller movie oh no
rough
waters or something uh
so uh
so now yeah so now i'm speeding down to
philly because i'm kind of like late for
this signing that he's doing
you know travis barker and it's not
close
and i've never even driven it before
so
i get i got my homeboy on the phone i'm
like this [__] must not know who
the [__] he's dealing with now i'm back
to like myself now
you know like
now i'm back to like stoic again i'm
back to me like i'm i'm not just
trying to be this other person in new
jersey let's appease the world and now
i'm back to myself and i'm like [__]
this [__] i'm down here so now i go to
the mod guys don't let me build this up
too much my stores are all anticlimactic
it's the way you tell it though you have
to end it and tell it right
because people go through [__] heart
crushing [__] like this that's
heartbreaking get lunch flip it over and
go again
that killed me i knew in that moment
i had a choice to make
so i get down to this mall i i talked to
my homeboy back from buffalo you know we
had affirmed that [__] didn't
know who he was dealing with we have
heard that yes he did not in fact know
who he was [__] with
and he didn't you'd have been astonished
if he knew i was a [__] rapper
you know i had chased down a record deal
simultaneously nobody nobody knew any of
that [__] yeah but i wasn't that i work
for
uh
so i get there and he's at like attilis
or something
so i get to the tillies and there's a
line in front of it i go to the back of
the line i got my manila envelope i got
all my [__] i'm getting myself ready now
my you know what i mean i know like damn
i got i got this whole situation now i
got to deal with
but just i was
i remember being ready to go in still
all right so i'm in the line and i'm
kind of waiting in the line i can tell
i'm like
you know he's not there yet
and then i'm waiting there for a while
maybe like 20 minutes well there was
there was a guy who was like you got a
pass
or he said something he's like no that
the this is just
the front of the line the line starts
way down like way the [__] down so then
i look and i realize oh i'm just at like
the very tip of the line
and so i would then walk
way down to the other side of the mall
like this
the line starts right there
yeah so now i wait in the back of the
line for a while
so then you go into the very very very
back i realized yes now i'm in the back
line i'm waiting which is i'm like
whatever
might as well wait i wait for a while
and then one of the workers comes and is
like hey if you don't got the pass might
as well get out of line
i was like
what pass
you had to buy you had to buy the
pre-order of his cd to get the pass for
this
to be able to meet him
you know
so now
i can't even [__] meet him
i didn't know that
i thought it was a [__] meet and
greet with travis barker but you had to
buy give the drummer some
pre-order to have the pass to meet him
at tilly's
i didn't know that
you should have ran in there
so by
there's a lot of people there now
so i get out of line i go up to the
front of the line
and i pick out some kids at the front of
the line
and i just open up my folder adam show
them the graphics and they're all like
oh [__]
it was a crazy ass collage graphic i
made photoshop
everything travis barker l.a his
cadillacs his kids his drumsticks all
this
i was like
you guys can have these
give him the cd you guys can have these
keep them have them sign them they're
like bro
and i gave him the [__] i gave him my
[__]
massive crowd basically started forming
people shoving me out of the way
and that was that
[Laughter]
i kind of [__] backed away
big ass sea of people
i can see everything nothing
are you wearing a white shirt
i feel like you were probably i don't
know i just see this oh marty that's
heartbreaking
ah
this is the end of raging terror
nothing good game nothing good well
something good wait what happened when
you went back and explained that you did
not work
so yeah no i mean so this is where the
good part of the story came because
as soon as i went back to the house i'm
like we're moving back
to new york it's [__] over okay
so that's it made me realize because i
was like okay
we're gonna live in new jersey for a
while then we're gonna buy an investment
property down in charlotte then we're
gonna save that money up and then with
the money that we use from our
investment property or whatever the [__]
we're gonna end up at california
that was the plan before we went to new
jersey now the plan was [__] all that
we're going to cali
but here you are and that made that
happen because if had that not
happened that way
we gotta find a five-minute version of
that story you gotta find a way to sell
it in five minutes because you know
travis parker will stay here one day and
we go by the way
thanks
considered that yeah
because yeah it sent me something
we put them on our list too
soon it was funny because uh
you never told me this story yeah it was
that was a really weird little time in
my life i went back to lackawanna like a
couple days like i got back i don't
i remember the horror and just feeling
like
there was nothing to do but to be like
all right we're just going to go back
that was really
it's still a win i think yeah of course
because this is
a win episode i think that story was
like that was a lot like no no it was an
accomplishment because we came back and
now in my mind i knew what i had to do
and i did it it was only
it was only maybe a year and a half two
years
from that point
that
you know like me and april got married
and then we left yeah basically
so who knows but travis barker
one day we do need you on the bike
talk about it make sure you saw those
[__] graphics got that down
what if he hasn't like i have this at my
house
that'd be incredible right
good [__] yeah yo well what time we at
about 120 120 yeah all right
we talked about a lot of stuff today
i got one more cool thing
i got one more cool win all right
all right
so if you haven't seen it you should
check it out on youtube it's called
break up with your dealer
and it's a commercial i did for a weed
company
i've never done production i've ever
done makeup and had a wardrobe never
done this and i've done that i've never
had
fake water rain machines we've never
done that before
so that was the coolest one of the
coolest experiences ever and i played a
pizza guy that also sells weed
they didn't know my history with that
exact job title until i explained it to
him on set charlie did not watch he'd
never seen that story time before he
goes what do you mean i go
whatever you're talking about this
anyway
go check it out break up with your
dealer
pre-roll
pre-roll free roll the dopest the dope
is that he has a wedding cake correct oh
it's girl scout winning cakes pink
um
so
i did that commercial a couple years ago
charlie he's my homie uh he helped me
filmed a lot of videos charlie's an
actor
you've probably seen if you watch
netflix like love shows i think it's
what it's called love i think charlie's
on that show he's on [__]
he's an actor he's my homie he's cool as
[__] he's in a bunch of stuff anyway
you'll recognize him when you see him in
the vlog probably
anyway he does a lot of weed content for
big companies
he does logistics for like all the house
plants [__] he basically got them legal
in california he does a lot of weed
stuff anyway
he's the one that got me into that first
commercial break up with the dealer he
pitched me he's like yo i know the
perfect guy for the [__] commercial
and it was great so fun
that was a youtube commercial it was a
commercial for youtube for their ad
that's all it was right it was [__]
great
but it's not tv
charlie calls me
sends me a storyboard i've never gotten
a storyboard
i'm not gonna say what company
but tomorrow today's saturday tomorrow
sunday i don't know what my call time is
i gotta look at it
we are filming i'm gonna be in a
commercial
the first in history the first weed
brand commercial on national television
oh [__]
all right i don't know how this
[__] i don't know how this is
happening but
i got the storyboard it looks [__]
cool i like it i play
a [__] weed truck driver a wee
delivery driver again
i'll just say it's a delivery service
commercial i won't say anything else but
yes
anyway it's from seed to sale by
planting to bagging to this and i'm the
guy that like drops it blah blah blah
but i'm having like lines and whatever
so it's gonna be like a
ups commercial it's gonna be all fun and
like dude
and i'm gonna be the dude so
i don't know when it's coming out but
tomorrow i film that [__] so
that's a win no matter what because it's
the first in [__]
history never before has there been a
weed brand commercial on nationals
it's only right that runs like a
commercial not just like a super bowl ad
you know mad men in a super bowl ad
no
this is a
commercial that runs on tv like
you would see [__] sherman charm yeah
in that [__] crazy there's like five
or six people in the whole thing
but i'm the i got the storyboard i have
it i don't know i probably shouldn't
show it but
it's so crazy it's got every [__]
angle every scene of what i'm doing what
i'm saying what i'm doing i'm like oh i
got this
i ride around with a pack in my seat
[Laughter]
you [__] i said it and then i
screenshotted it i went through rosie's
phone
because i asked her hey i need to find a
certain picture so she's like here start
at the beginning so i went through her
phone she has 29 000 pictures that you
hadn't seen rosie has the same ip
because she doesn't get [__] up like i
do she has the same ip address in icloud
i went back to the first time we ever
hung out i saw our entire relationship
in this [__] phone the other day
and i saw a lot of my first youtube i
mean i mean my first instagram [__] and
i remember i always used to say this it
was in my bio
i found a picture of it screenshotted
and it said
when we goes legal i want to be the one
that makes the commercials and it's what
i used to have in my tagline of my bio
instagram and finally tomorrow prophecy
finally tomorrow [__] it's
coming let's go it's coming so yeah
that's tomorrow i can't say the brand
but shout out to charlie for including
me shout out to charlie for thinking of
me and [__] and yeah so you're gonna see
my stupid [__] face on national
[__] tv maybe instagram will stop
[__] hating on me like hey
the kid from the got milk commercial
article before
yeah the billboards
forbes magazine article comes out this
next week
for thedopeshop.com and it covers
how i started all my cannabis stuff how
i started doing all of our [__] the
podcast what led into this we'll let
into that and how we started the
dopashop.com
this thing is so covered in [__] it's
the the one thing about the cave covered
joints i can't smoke um when i'm on
camera that much because once i get the
key from my fingers i'm allergic to
wheat you know that you remember that
one episode
once i get key for my fingers and if i
touch my face i'm going to break out in
a little high for about 20 minutes
even when i touch caked weed i can't
touch my face there's something about it
or my forearms it's like a fish being
allergic to water it's so weird it's a
lot of my friends that are growers same
thing they go through the plants they
get little for about 20 minutes you're
just so
i don't know what it's like hyper
allergic now but i smoke the [__] out of
them but not on camera because all on
the reviews yeah but
not on this i don't want you guys to see
the big welts because it happened during
the uh
whose episode was it where i'm like [__]
dude i gotta remember to wipe it off a
little bit because there's so much keef
on our pre-rolls it goes all the way to
the filter that's the [__] filter's
covered it's covered almost dude like
there's so much we just go hard with it
just dunk it instead of like
at the end
i mean it's it's the best thing it's
just i'm allergic as [__] to [__] try
closing keith it makes me break out if i
touch my face and if it's good keefe
it really makes me break out
but i just want bums all over my [__]
face right now we're doing an episode so
i will smoke that at the end i actually
have one right here um
sorry forbes article's coming out
dopeyshop.com
[__] forbes is coming out the
commercial i filmed tomorrow i'm really
excited for that [__]
um
this has been a big win episode oh yeah
super super sick
super tight we're gonna say by probably
about september crazy we're gonna be and
kind of probably full swing with the new
season three
and guys that's just going to mean so
many amazing guests so many
different new brand partners that are
going to help us do our thing getting a
cool little situation not that our
guests aren't awesome now it's just the
like we said earlier the fact of like
it's not just two pie kids oh they're
they're backed by this
who
that's that oh [__] yeah we'll go on the
show like yeah on real shows you don't
get booked by the host yeah we have to
do it in our booking agent it's
different not a good look as much as
have real productions have teams that
tyson's not going hey
kevin hart could you please
hit me up with your looking engines
let's try to work out a time and we're
not saying we're mike tyson then we're
not saying that i'm just saying
not a professional look yeah in real
professional shows
we're just trying to be a real show
let's say we're not but we're just
trying to step that up and we will never
stop
continuing to try to do that yep
this is weird huh it's a little odd
knowing like
yeah that shit's all real this episode
it's really weird for me because it's
like looking at their set like i'm one
of the dudes i'm one of the dudes that
works there basically like but now i'm
on the camera yeah yeah just sick
i mean like that isn't really i'm kind
of paving the lane there i feel like
that's why i'm happy like you're not
over there anymore yeah like this is
such a better feel
it's so much better like like we're in
the same shot dude
this was so much more of a like natural
conversation it feels so i love this man
it's so cool
oh man because like i always say it's
like it's not the producer situation
it's like the producer's right here
and it's more of like co-host up and the
producer's arms are just doing this
while you're in the conversation type
[__] i don't know that's how i feel
about it because like the first couple
you're like hey what's up
and it was like no you talk a lot more
talk a lot more it's funny i don't know
i [__] like it
i appreciate you guys yeah because
that's just everybody likes that [__]
everybody's so nice that it's just like
yeah everybody's so nice i really
appreciate it i can't respond
everybody's comments but they really
mean a lot i really like when i read a
nice comment people say nice [__] all
the time it really means a lot
you know yeah because they get it's all
about what you see what you put out man
thank you guys for being so cool and we
get fired up knowing that you guys are
going to get fired up well yeah half of
why
we go
the first thing we said like the fans
are going to go [__] nuts that's
literally what we said we went outside
that's the first thing you said
oh i [__] know it
it's more about that it's not even like
us it's like i can't [__] wait to
tell you guys some [__]
it's so fun dude it's [__] awesome um
big win for everybody big win for
everything every oh
oh
last thing before i get out of here
sorry
it feels so different now last thing
before we get out of here
wow
how different is it dude sure that's a
training gun for this [__] oh trent
you're bringing [__] together
over here i love it thank you um
super big win biggest win of my entire
[__] existence
non-business related because other than
that like we're [__] business [__] is
going awesome i [__] love it thank
you guys for watching thank you for
helping and supporting
you don't have to buy [__] just like it
it's watching thanks
[__] appreciate people always say i
wish i could donate but you don't have
to [__] do your time your time is a
bigger donation than your tip the
[__] donations great thank you so
much if you're donating money crazy
awesome
jesus that was a beer burp sorry guys
this beer on a saturday morning
i feel like an 18.
sorry no 21 i feel 21
[Laughter]
sorry
here we go
you guys ready for this
dude this whole episode is just maybe
like
there's a lot of good things going on
alright so
next week
next week rosie and i have a tour
next week rosie and i have a tour of a
house
i found a house
i showed you the house
i showed you it right
yeah
okay
i have a tour next week of a [__]
house i'm trying to buy and if so i will
have it and be moved in this [__] by
november i have to wait for this that he
already gave me the timeline
all right last night i wanted to talk
about this because it's it's a [__]
i'm glad i [__] remember because it
would have been stupid if i didn't like
yo it's about good stuff today
i might not get this house
yeah i saw a picture
and this pool has a rolls royce that
lived there and it doesn't fit in the
garage
my monte carlo is long
i have to part my money carl outside
after got restored that's one of the
weird things about outlet you can be in
a baller ass mansion and your street is
a [__] tight squeeze when you try to
get down
you might have a tight ass driveway or
some [__] okay so i'll be able to talk
about it now because i know i'm probably
not i want to go look at it anyway
just to get pre-approved get getting to
know the guy because there's more stuff
whatever
and then
i hope he doesn't watch the show because
i think april's the one that's gonna
help us get the house i hope he doesn't
watch a show man
i just want to see your house i'm so
sorry [__] i'm i'm not gonna buy it
i'm sorry i gotta find a better house
anyway
you ready for this [__] never in my life
that i think this gta gta [__] would be
possible in my entire life
guys
i can tell where it's at because i'm
probably not going to move in and if i
do i'll be pissed
that i told everybody where i live okay
but it's okay
rosie and i have a [__] meeting for
this house
this [__] house
to the left of my of the backyard is the
hollywood sign
straight in the distance is downtown
through the mountains
and it's in the hollywood hills i found
a gated
community in the hollywood hills
i don't know how this zillow has never
showed me this neighborhood before
because i searched zillow i told him i'm
on it every day at least like 20 minutes
before i go to sleep just like all right
what's popping up because i want to
[__] move i'm tired of my [__]
building saying smoking charges and it's
not even me
they gave me a three-day notice to move
out and i told my life i'd tell you i
told my lawyer and he goes don't [__]
worry and they have not bugged me yet
it's been like two weeks
i'm not even there sometimes and they've
like smoking you could they come up to
my building oh security guard i'm like
bro
i just walked most of the time
99.9 of the time it's not me
which blows my mind i wouldn't know if
i'm smoking it up [__] i smoked
it up there one time with og and they
never even showed up and i always smoke
like a zip with his ass sam and they
didn't come that time anyway sorry i'm
tired of living in my [__] apartment
i'm tired of it that's why i'm so
excited for a house i'm so over it but
this [__] is off mulholland it's
right on it's a gated community on
mulholland drive
if you're familiar you probably know
where it's at but it's in the [__]
mountains guys
and when i looked at this [__] house
i'm like rosie this would be so sick
and then she called the realtor i didn't
know she was gonna call
and the price on zillow was
like 700 bands more than what the house
is really going for
yeah that changes everything the housing
market's changing right now
yeah i'm like damn that's an expensive
house like actually 700k less like
oh it's yeah that's a fort i could do it
and then they're like what's your down
payment went i could do it and then me
rosie looked at each other we were at
the we're at the office and went
we're in my house together right now are
you [__] kidding me right now are we
gonna go get a [__] house for like
it's just like
it's just weird this whole [__] past
month has been so weird for me
i feel like oh i'm growing up oh my
[__] god i'm finally doing it
it's like you just got your heart at me
like yeah
[__] yeah thank you guys for [__]
everything just painted that [__]
thing
today as we were setting up
our house was beef stew [__] brown and
mustard yellow for the past beef
sunscreen
[__] brown mustard yellow for real it's
a nice clean gray white pad like it is
so [__] fresh now oh the picture is a
different house now it looks like a
house on the beach yeah we like it
feel moved in because the outer of the
house was so shitty i didn't think it
looked shitty before it was so shitty
the homeowners association said hey you
[__] you gotta paint your house even
though you bought it that way they never
gave it to the guy before yeah the house
was in shambles but
thank you guys i want to figure out a
way to [__] post this somehow without
just showing the [__] in front of the
house uh
i want to show the house off to the fans
because they know and i don't that's not
yeah there's no way to do that but
you know what i think you'll be okay
because they just know you live in
orange county they don't know where you
live i don't know yeah and you know what
just remember it's a real nice house
it's white gray a little bit of blue
very nice it's just yeah it's a dream
come true it's crazy because then you're
like buffalo
i'm so [__] glad yeah i'm not there
doing what i was doing because
everybody's thinking that like dude i'll
be there one day like you [__] will
yeah that's why i would be a good one of
the first episode is so important i just
wanted to
really with this little success that
we're having i just want to really not
let anybody [__] forget about all
that [__]
yeah yeah [__] yeah exactly
not once did we go
you know how much money we're gonna be
oh [__] [__] you
like hopefully we get paid hopefully
hopefully [__] you that'd be stupid
that'd be amazing but
still no matter what the show's gonna
look better more stress off us no matter
what off of marty he gets forward free
days of editing back that means
two dopey yellow videos a week that's
what i'm trying to do we just don't have
the up
it's impossible right now you can't
there's no way we could
do it and me film and do the other [__]
it's not gonna happen it's the only way
to just yeah continue to keep leveling
up yeah we just wanna i just wanna put
up more con we don't even get paid for
dope and really content
one day maybe youtube will pay us and
then we'll be like yo
three videos a week i don't give a [__]
we can just hire more editors
because you know how that would much
who else on youtube is so in the red
like oh man
without them not paying me
i'm probably like [__] 150k deep
of paying for editing and everything
over the past like three years and
filming and buying [__] buying wii for
the videos doing that
building [__] during the recreation rent
for a building
all right you know who gives a [__] how
much money but we've always made it back
in other ways like that's the point
that's why i have pushed trees to try to
[__] scale it your story is going to
just be legendary like in the textbooks
of
how to make money through the internet
oh yeah when people look back like he
literally made this possible he turned a
[__] meme into a clothing brand and
then he used the clothing brand to fund
the
youtube channels including the podcast
and then bam now the podcast went and
then the notoriety off youtube led to
the led to the dopest
and like that
now it's coming together but there's all
these years of being in the red just
hoping it would work out
that's how it goes i knew it would
but you never believe it when it does
you know what i mean you always have
that image like i know it will [__] that
programming the earth right now no it's
going to happen [__] yeah uh yep
yeah i know what car is going to be yeah
cause it's like when it came it's like
yeah
you're really
you're desperate you're malcolm in the
middle this can't be real yeah there's
no way that it would let it happen to me
yeah there's no way that for sure
there's always that little bit like a
little bit
but it's [__]
to me it's like once i change my mind
and i'm like this isn't who i am this is
who i
am and i just love this show so much you
just [__] just brought it back
yeah yes it's cool to just have been out
of the present moment for so long
like being the dude in the cubicle like
you're looking at me i'm talking to you
but i'm not even me
because who i am is this dude off
doing this [__] that we're doing right
now
and now it's like i finally get to be
him so we're just getting started
now not to me to myself i'm like all
right well now what now you got
everything you've been bitching about
this whole time you got what you wanted
now what are you gonna do with it that's
exactly the point we're both in
in all aspects of life too
i'm just like like a year behind you in
that i need to get a house i need to
move out because i'm stressed every
[__] day
yeah you don't worry about kids [__]
no i'm talking about living yeah yeah
you know me i'm [__] drug dealer
brain like who the [__] is walking by my
[__] apartment 30 people a day
i have an apartment building and i'm
like always like
it's hard to have a running camera out
there i have the cameras though
constantly just going off
but i'm saying like
we're both in the like all right cool
you [__] got it like with the house
my oh my god it's gonna [__] happen i
can't believe it's real it's weird
and now it's like so what else are we
gonna do mm-hmm all this stuff all the
bases are covered yeah what the [__]
else can we do and you guys have seen it
happen you bro
we both were just trying when we first
started doing the show
right and then what now you have to [__]
now you moved
now we're doing this [__] now it's full
time on your hand for this [__] yeah
and everything's working oh my god it's
so weird knowing that like yo on this
show you guys have seen the everything
all over everything coming spoke that
[__] into existence full-time podcaster
i was not even a [__] podcaster when
i wrote that book i was
letting people know how to do something
that i hadn't even done yet
you know but it's like but you got to
put that out there
and then it can come to be i you know i
used to be jealous of nick not jealous
but like i'm like damn nick because nick
was the engineer nick nick's uh nick
gets to meet everybody nick is in the
mix he's in the conversation he's in the
studio it's his spin on the shows he's
hands-on it was way different than what
i was doing just from my garage from my
office it's not a it's a thing of
looking up like damn i would love to get
there i don't know how to work these
[__] cameras yeah and it's not like i
wish i could do i wish i was you it's
that's the envy and the jealousy why are
you there that's not more of like [__] i
wish i could do what you do i would love
to be where the [__] you can get to yeah
i can get there and look what the [__]
going on
if this wasn't you i would have punched
the [__] table
uh
i know cause like it i was talking about
this like it could have happened with so
many people i've had so many i've had
thousands of clients in my career
hundreds of clients entertainers and
[__]
but it's just the fact that it happened
how it did just lets me know there's a
greater good to this [__] oh yeah
something bigger here we're in this show
for the long haul
nate diaz flex nate diaz flex for
everyone out there not watching and
listening marty nade diaz flex too while
he said it
he has
nerdy skinny kid from uh little giants
flex oh [__]
in the mirror with the glasses
for everyone out there that got that
we're friends and if you didn't we could
be friends just watch the little giants
the ice box
spike don't play with girls xbox
annexation of puerto rico that's when
you know the show's closing down
and we're about to end we're both just
you know when little kids are like
exhausted they start saying random [__]
that's us like yo we're both high where
topics are done like
oh giants is a great movie
we're all just like
deep into the early 90s
spike don't put every night and massage
his neck with warm milk
that's what he was doing to spike you
remember so much more about [__]
one reference but think about it though
all you need is one
rick moranis i know you don't act we
know you don't do anything anymore and
we know half our audience is going to go
i got to google who requires this
because i'm not you know really onto
that movie like that or in maybe even
not over 25 to 30 but ever a lot of our
audience is over 30 though our [__]
back end yeah
18 to 2 to 30 is
not as big as 30 and to like 45 and
that's like that oh you're a full grown
up like you're working you probably got
kids and you still watch thank you for
making time [__] we appreciate
that [__] they get a lot of
these references yes and that's why i
bring it up not saying younger fools
don't have kids and jobs and
responsibilities i'm not saying that
but they might get our references so
hey miranda's
how about little giants and [__] i
shrunk the kids at [__] oh rick miranda
has ever seen space balls he's
essentially darth vader
what a good movie i already started
itching yep oh [__]
[__] red already i can feel it
starting
so ah dude any keef
any keith dude or trichomes every time
you're in here rolling up before the
challenge you're just sneezing away
dude i smoke really heavy strong og it's
so [__] caked up it's just in the air
when i'm grinding just
it's like uh an abominable snowman being
allergic to snow yeah it's like ah i'm
itchy all the time
yeah yeah when i go to the if i go to
like a public gym
you will smell weed
it's not good
that's crazy actually it makes me feel
like you know do you have a problem huh
[__] you smell like sweating dabs
the dabs are different though dab when
you take dab
dab heavily and go to the gym you don't
smell like weed
but if you smoke a lot of weed that [__]
comes out of your pores and for all the
hotheads out there you guys know that's
[__] true
um
all right we got through everything we
started talking about the 90s so you
know it's time to check the landing gear
yeah
every time like so you know
oh [__] i can't because i want to start
again i was about to talk about the
whole mask scene when they're talking to
the cop all right
you didn't hear anything last night she
shot a 12 gauge
we're going to get out of here guys
we're like
we got to stop this is a great [__]
this is fun i love this table i love
this table first time setting up first
this is sick as [__] you guys got the
new news on all aspects of
[__] life
everything's going really well right now
super sick thank you guys for making it
possible thank you for being here
another thing maybe do an overlay if you
haven't already please drop a like on
the video we'd appreciate that if you're
on apple you're out spotified leave a
star
or review or whatever the hell you want
to call it you know drop a review that'd
be sick as [__] but if you're a dick and
you came here just to be an [__]
don't drop a review because it's going
to be mean
there's nobody nobody watching that
would do such thing [__] there's some
there's some weirdos
but it's okay thank you guys so much for
being here also youtube we [__]
love you man
i'll also say thanks i guess
don't restrict our accomplishment video
please because this is a fun positive
video
finally we won we finally won on all's
aspects we had nothing bad to say yeah
and there's no losses in this episode
we'll see you two breaks right when i
say it i was thinking like what else is
gonna happen
the lights behind me the table collapses
on you oh
trent
guys thank you so much for being here
marty
thank you for
right here this is [__] crazy
this is better
guys thank you so much for being here
marty got anything else you want to say
before we get out of here
i've said it all today thank you guys
thank you thinking that too thank
everybody for this is all these wins
we're talking about are wins for
everybody this is one big ass team
coming to [__] [__] up
yes
thank you guys for being here sorry
we're so explicit all platforms but this
is us
and remember
all this this whole change we're going
to be doing with the new production team
and doing all this
they know what they're getting into
so we did this
without having to change or censor
ourselves for the first 10 minutes at
least that's just this is so we don't
think we just [__] for the first 10
minutes besides that we didn't have to
do anything weird
we're not creeps
nothing is going on
we're doing the same [__]
and uh
yeah we got this deal going and shout
out to malcolm for [__]
believing in our [__] bringing us on
board exactly
appreciate you guys [__]
yeah pretty cool [__] stopped
but more on the work mode yeah yeah it's
like yeah we'll get stoked now let's
think about the next 10 years of [__]
work robots put on yep [__] ready for
it i'm ready for it i gotta just get
that mario lopez look though i gotta get
into shape and be like yo you still look
very i'm like i know i'm in my 40s now
it's been a while
like yeah mario lopez mario is 80. look
at this [__] look dirty
whatever's going on yeah i know i'm
about to start getting my [__] together
too
oh you're damn sure absolutely
kickboxing kid yeah yeah i signed up for
the kickboxing gym about three months
ago oh well now you're gonna have time
this about to be sick all right we're
about to have a lot of fun more time
from uh marty and i sitting right here
not in the distance for marty and i and
everybody at the dope as usual podcast
we want to say you guys thank you so
much for supporting us thank you for
being here if you're on the road please
drive safe if you're at work don't worry
it gets better but if you're at work and
you love work [__] awesome crush that
[__] and if you're at school i'm [__]
sorry it gets better
i hope your degree is worth it
yeah
keep going though if you like school i
[__] appreciate you because there's
not many of you left all right thank you
guys so much for being here for
everybody working everybody doing their
thing
have a dope ass day from the dope as
usual podcast oh let's go i switched it
up a little bit
this is just a tad today
honestly i didn't mean to i was just
like i'm [__] high and i was staring
at that thing right there on the table i
just got distracted
[Laughter]
well i mean it's [__] gray and black
and there's a white crumb
that's not even why that's over
all right bro it's middle of the [__]
morning
oh we can do this now
you